yeah she has my drug ring where is it i
haven't seen it oh i have it
okay yeah i keep it nice and you know
secure but i'm just saying besides that
because i don't wear
um fancy jewelry at all like i don't own
a single like
gold anything nothing yeah well no i
thinking with the drug ring
i think that you want your reflection
okay yeah you got high
and you wanted it you got you had some
fun
no it was stressful it was oh yeah
because i went to like five jewelry
stores
why five though because i've never been
to a jewelry store so
some of them were looking shady i like
the way you say jewelry store
yeah so i would walk in and it's like
and i would look around and it was
and it has nothing to do with the race
of the people whatever
right not being real yeah no
microaggression baby
oh yes did you guys talk about this on
bad friends
we did microaggressions yeah
microaggression and microassaults
because i was it was so cute one day
bobby
woke me up um from a nap
and he was like do you know what a
microaggression is
i was like um
yes you've built an entire career baby
the style of comedy that i chose to you
know
do um it had it was something weird with
it you know what i mean
yeah but i mean and then when they put a
terminology to it
then you just kind of you just awaken i
just find it cute that like you arrived
five years late
on the conversation like and it was cute
too like he went into a rabbit hole of
just watching
you know the videos universities put out
of students yeah yeah
and you know what they consider
microaggressions micro assaults
like and and he watched like three hours
of it and then he came back to me he's
like
oh my god this is all i do all day yeah
yeah well
because a lot of at first i thought it
was a comedy
it's pretty it's a little crazy these
days of what because
because the so the one that i um
well i was going on a the reason why i
found out about microaggressions because
i was uh
i was googling like youtubing power high
school stuff
for my from my high school why i don't
know why but uh
i have no idea yeah but i was and uh
look it up
and they had a video on microaggressions
i'm like
wow what is high school so i clicked on
it and at first i thought it was a
series of sketches
like comedy sketches yeah right and at
the end
somebody was like don't do any of these
this is wrong whatever right but i was
like
what are the sketches they had they had
four high school kids
yeah walking down you know the hallway
somebody sees a penny and and goes
i think it's like hey chloe aren't you
going to pick that up you're jewish
right and i and then i went ah i was
cackling in my bed yeah
that's funny you know what i mean
then but then it's like i realized no
that probably hurts people
it's but see no but here's the thing
yeah i know so many jewish people that
would [ __ ] laugh at that and roast me
it depends like you have a relationship
with a person
does that person know the context of
your heart do you have like if there's
so many things that you
i just look you and i we operate a
certain way like i
i don't throw microaggressions out at
strangers or people i don't know or
people in the workplace like
you have to conduct the level of
professionalism bobby
but but when it was with friends and
like [ __ ] that then a roast battle would
be cancelled
yeah yeah because one time i was at my
my manager happens to be jewish
yeah and i pulled out a 20 bill and put
her from her face like are you drooling
and she goes yeah and she was like shut
up you know what i mean but it's like
and we
both laughed about it yeah and it's like
those little things
right she's also known you for 25. i
know but i'm saying in my head
because i didn't know that it would it
had to listen
in institutional areas like if you're
working at the government or you're at
school or
at your job what not right
i get it you're publicly out there
you're with strangers or people you
don't know that well
obviously microaggressions are wrong
right
but i think it's mighty fine to do right
when you're amongst
people that you love and you know
because i'm telling you right now i'm
telling
all my white friends don't
stop micro regressing me i like it
we should make a shirt yeah don't stop
micro i i like it
sometimes though it doesn't fly with me
like especially in with my filipino
family
that's who it is it's always always the
comment i think this is why it bothers
me the comment is
always about looks and appearance and
it's always
a tiny remark about you know oh you've
gained weight oh
what like my my my sister no my
microgravity
my sister no it's always an appearance
thing like they never lead with high
hello it's always like why do you look
like that and oh you got fat
we've been eating mcdonald's for six
months yeah like that type of [ __ ]
yeah yeah it's like i you know like when
i see eric griffin i don't hate to say
his name but i did
so why do you want to say that's a
microaggression for him yeah
yeah and and i um when i see him i want
to say
so many microaggressions right i just
think he's so ugly to me
yeah but that's what you guys do to each
other that's your language of play
they're not
i love him i love him with all my heart
but he's not offended so it's not a mic
he is a little bit
but i like you know what i like is i
like attacking him
right and i love his response to me it
feels good
interesting you know he talks about i'm
fat
you're fat yeah yeah look at you you
don't mean it i love it you know i mean
it feels good
but i just still i'm not going to ever
do away with microaggressions when it
comes to my own family and friends and
in comedy yeah i mean the day that you
stopped calling me the touch
it might be over for us yeah yeah like
it's he's gotten to the point where
every day he makes fun of my nose to
where
i'm like i've asked him like do you
think i need a nose job because i've
actually looked into one yeah solely for
the fact that he won't stop calling me
the two she's like
yeah well like if you're walking from
the [ __ ] kitchen
yeah down in the garage a minute before
you get in here
your nose comes in first microaggression
microaggression that's like no no that's
something that's
that's impression macro assault that's
the background
it's just a joke baby okay i love you so
much it's just a joke
i love everything about you thank you
okay i love your eyebrows i love your
see that's a i know he has a thing about
my i don't it's
that's a [ __ ] compliment wait do you
love her eyebrows
look at she calls me the worst things
look at this [ __ ]
i don't call you that sitting here
that's fat [ __ ] no yeah yeah
it's like what's the worst no i call you
like my little rumble
no
my little potato spot yeah yeah hey guys
we're gonna take a really quick break